Okay,
what time is it?
I started when 6:30.
I shouldn't stop them.
Thank you.
I'm going to go for five more minutes
and then I'll wrap this up.
I want to talk about intersectionality
and,
and white privilege a bit.
So.
So I first said,
well,
we analyzed Marxism,
we analyzed postmodernism.
I suggested that postmodernism was a way
for the Marxist to keep going under a
new guys.
I suggested that Marxism was
fundamentally based on hatred rather
than sympathy and empathy.
I suggested that the corpses were the,
the evidence for that.
Um,
I told you why I think postmodernism is
fundamentally wrong.
Um,
now I want to talk to you a little bit
about white privilege.
So the first thing that I,
and I haven't got this quite figured out
yet,
I can't quite figure out why the
postmodernists have made the canonical
distinctions.
They've made race,
ethnicity,
sexual proclivity,
sexual,
gender identity.
Let's say those are four dimensions
along which people vary,
but there's a very large number of
dimensions along which people vary,
right?
In fact,
given that there's an infinite number of
ways of interpreting the world,
you can immediately point out that
there's an infinite number of dimensions
along which people vary,
and so then the postmodern question is,
why would you privilege some of those
dimensions over the other?
And I would say,
well,
because it sustains your bloody Marxist
interpretation.
That's why,
but you're not going to say that because
it marginalizes,
right?
You've marginalized that so you can
ignore it.
So that's one of the fun things about
postmodernism.
You can.
I have a very vulgar image in my mind,
but I won't share that with you,
but you can infer it.
Here's some ways people differ.
Intelligence,
temperament,
geography,
historical time.
You live now in not 100 years ago.
Attractiveness.
That's a big.
That's a big one.
Would you imagine?
You could.
We won't.
We won't go there.
Either.
You eat.
It's advantageous to be young.
You've got potential disadvantageous to
be old.
You've got wealth health.
That's a good one.
Sex women have advantages.
Men have advantages.
Maybe one has more than the other.
It's not self evident.
Women live about eight years longer
there.
Athleticism,
well,
family structure,
friendship,
education,
well then there's the classic,
you know,
postmodern once,
race,
ethnicity,
etc.
Why not those other dimensions of
variation.
There's no evidence that they're less
important.
In fact,
there's quite a bit of evidence that
they're more important,
so like Why not consider them?
Then you get intersectionality.
This is one of the things that's really
comical I think because the
postmodernists identity politics types
actually realized this.
They thought,
well,
okay,
race and gender.
Fair enough.
What if you're.
What if you're a black woman?
Well,
that's a problem because,
well now you've got two dimensions of
differentiation.
What the hell are we going to do about
that?
And what if you're,
what if you're gay and black and female?
Well then what if you're not very bright
and gay and black and female,
and then what if you're ugly and not
very bright and gay and black and
female,
and like you can keep playing that game.
You can keep playing that game and an
infinite number of ways because there's
an infinite number of ways to categorize
things.
As The postmodern authority pointed out,
and so the intersectionality theorist
came along to plug the hole,
but they don't know where they're going.
They don't understand that the logical
conclusion of intersectionality is
individuality because there's so many
different ways of categorizing people's
advantages and disadvantages that if you
take that all the way out to the end,
you say,
well,
the individuals,
the ultimate minority,
and that's exactly right and that's
exactly what the west discovered and you
know the intersection lists,
so get there if they don't kill everyone
first,
so onto white privilege.
So it's really interesting to find out
where these ideas come from because it's
usually the scholarship is so awful,
you just cannot possibly believe it.
It's just absolutely.
It wouldn't.
In at the university of toronto,
in the psychology department,
the original paper on white privilege
wouldn't have received a passing grade
for the hypothesis part of a
undergraduate honors thesis.
We're not even close.
There's no methodology at all.
The person who wrote It,
it was called white privilege and male
privilege.
A personal account of coming to see
correspondences through work in women's
studies.
Well,
first of all,
personal account,
it's like,
sorry.
No,
I'm
so she,
she listed a bunch of ways that she
thought she says these are personal
personal examples of her unearned
privilege or unearned privilege that she
saw as she experienced in the 19
seventies,
19 eighties.
So this part of the way.
So this idea is the opinion of one
person who wrote one paper that has
absolutely no empirical backing
whatsoever,
which is a set of hypotheses which had
never been subject to any statistical.
Like if I ask you a bunch of questions,
it's not obvious how many questions I'm
asking you because I could say,
how tall are you?
Or I could say,
if you're laying on the ground,
how extended would you be?
Like that?
Two questions.
It's like,
no,
it's one question.
It's just asked two ways and the way you
figure out if you ask someone a bunch of
questions,
how many questions you're asking them is
by doing something called a factor
analysis,
which is kind of in an elementary form
now of social science investigation.
If you make a questionnaire,
you have to subject it to a factor
analysis because you've got to find out
how many questions you're asking because
you might think it's 60,
but it's probably not.
It's probably five.
That's the big five,
by the way.
Anyways.
Who cares about that?
There's no such thing as methodology.
Anyways,
that's all part of the oppressive white
male european patriarchy,
so we can just not bother with that and
we can pin a few notes about how we
think the world is constructed and then
we can screw up the entire political
system two decades later.
Okay,
so here's your white privilege lists.
Some of it.
There's like 50 things I can if I wish
arrange to be in the company of people
of my race,
most of the time,
if I should need to move,
I can be pretty sure of renting or
purchasing housing in an area which I
can afford and in which I would want to
live.
That's actually a wealth thing.
By the way.
I can be pretty sure that my neighbors
in such a location will be neutral or
pleasant to me.
I can go shopping alone most of the
time,
pretty well assured that I will not be
followed or harassed.
I can turn on the television or open to
the front page of the paper and see
people of my waist race widely
represented when I'm told about our
national heritage or about civilization,
I am shown that people of my color made
it what it is.
There's 50 of those I think something
like that.
Okay.
Is that white privilege?
Is that like majority privilege?
It's the same tree.
You go to China,
you're chinese.
Is the same?
True.
If you're chinese,
does the majority privilege benefits?
Majority privileges.
Like isn't that just part of living
within your culture?
So let's say you live in your culture,
you're privileged as a member of that
culture,
while obviously that's what the culture
is for.
That's what it's for.
Why would you bother building the damn
thing if it didn't accrue benefits to
you?
Now you mighT say,
well,
one of the consequences that it accrues
fewer benefits to those who aren't in
the culture.
yeah,
but you can immediately associate that
with race.
You can't just do that.
Say it's white,
privileged does many things it could be
certainly could be well and the
intersectional people have already
figured out that there's many things
that could be so like what the hell?
Seriously,
well what's going on while we let these
pseudo disciplines into the university
because we're stupid and guilty
seriously and they have no
methodological requirements and plenty
of power and plenty of time to produce
nonsensical research and produce like
resentful activists and now we're
bearing the fruits of that.
IT's not pretty so privilege.
Well,
the other thing you might notice is that
to attribute to the individuals of a
community,
the attributes of that community on the
basis of their racial identity is called
racism.
That's what racism is.
There's no other way of defining it.
It's attributing to the individual the
characteristics of the group as if the
group was homogenous.
Now the intersection of people have
already decided that's not a fair game
because there's so many differences
between people,
but the postmodernist don't care about
logical coherence because they regard
logical coherence.
Here it comes again as a creation of the
white european male patrIarchal
structure that's designed to oppress the
oppressed,
and that's technically the case.
So logical,
incoherence,
it doesn't matter,
and you could say,
well,
if you act out your logically incoherent
ideas in the world,
you're going to run face first into a
brick wall,
and the postmodern answer to that is
there's actually no real world.
It's all interpretation.
So there's no,
there's no having that discussion,
but the modernists don't care because
they don't believe that discussion
between people of different power groups
as possible.
Anyways.
So here we are.
Well,
so I made a case tonight,
you know,
I'll go over it.
What's the case?
The postmodernists are wrong.
They're philosophically naive,
they're right about an infinite number
of interpretations and wrong about a
finite number of viable interpretations
and that's like that's,
that's death.
That's the end of postmodernists theory
and that's not the only way in which
they're wrong.
They're wrong and a bunch of other ways,
but they're more subsidiary.
The marxists.
They're not just wrong.
They're wrong and murderous or wrong,
murderous and genocidal.
Unless you think murderers and genocidal
doesn't mean wrong,
and you can think that there's lots of
would be revolutionaries who would be
happy to have blood running in the
street if they had their chance for
revenge and the opportunity to move up
the hierarchy of charity so you can.
You don't have to think that murder and
genocide is wrong,
especially if the right people are
murdered in genocided.
Right?
That's actually part of the part of the
whole equation.
But if you're willing to think that
murder and genocide on a mass scale
across many cultures,
over many decades is wrong.
Then marxism is wrong and the
postmodernist don't get to just come
along and adopt marxism as a matter of
sleight of hand because they're marx's
theory didn't work out and they figured
out a rationalization.
They don't get to get away with that
because it's too dangerous.
IT's too dangerous to the rest of us and
we don't and it isn't necessary for us
who are trying with the small part of
our hearts that might be oriented
towards the good to allow people who are
manipulating us with historical
ignorance and philosophical of hand to
render a so god damn guilty about what
our ancestors may or may not have done
so that we allow our shame and our guilt
to be.
To be used as tools to manipulate us
into accepting a future that we do not
want to have.
And that's that.
Thank you.